Savannah Georgia has a rich military
history this month in partnership with
our local cable affiliate Comcast we
explore Savannah's history and literary
culture next local George and author
Howard Wasden talks about some modern
military history his book is SEAL Team 6
SEAL team 6 is a tier 1
counter-terrorist unit what I mean by
tier 1 like you've got the other SEAL
Teams SEAL team 6 has additional funding
logistical support and training that
makes them a tier 1 unit which means
they can be called out at a moment's
notice and just go anywhere in the world
and do a into a counter-terrorist off
what else what exactly stuff them apart
from the other teams is it just where
they're sent or training and all that -
well they're so there's some enhanced
training the big thing CQB you're
familiar with the term CQB close
quarters battle is probably the biggest
thing that sets them apart from the
other teams close quarters battle like
Ruger room fighting like in this house
aboard a cruise ship for example
airplane you know just inside a building
that let's take it to a whole new level
at SEAL Team 6 versus the other SEAL
Teams so if somebody what exactly does
their training entail first day of
training but what do you what are you
supposed to do well you gotta understand
you're already dealing with an elite
caliber warrior here all the seals that
would screen to go to six have already
gotten all their land warfare training
all the urban training winter warfare
diving skydiving so you've already got
like an elite warrior so the training
that would go into fine-tuning these
guys for a specific mission would it
would be that CQB more a lot more sky
diving for example SEAL Team six does a
lot more sky diving than the other teams
so they learn how to stack their
canopies like coming in to land etc so
they just take everything to a whole new
level as far as getting a whole team on
target and can you tell us about your
time during the the seals what was your
experience like well you know my
experience overall was good you know my
career-ender was during the whole
Blackhawk down to Walker where I was
shot but everything up to that was great
you know had a lot
of good ops at SEAL team 2 and even at
SEAL Team 6 when I was in Somalia I had
a lot of great ups you know including
help and uh helping other people and
working with the CIA it's it's just you
know everybody remembers the one bad op
that I had which was on October 3rd 93
can you tell us for those who don't know
details about that battle
yeah well basically we'd been in Somalia
for two or three months and we've been
working trying to find my hair Mohammed
Farah Aidid who was the bad guy the bad
clan leader and on that particular day
we had some intelligence we us two Delta
Force guys and the Rangers has some
intelligence that he was going to be at
a certain hotel as it turns out I think
and I think common with most people
think that it was an ambush so during
that combat 18 Americans were killed
72 I think or injured you know and it
was a really bad day
the worst thing about that battle is
while we had broken the back of the
al-qaeda backed clan we tuck tail and
left we just left that unfinished over
there which gave them a eight year you
know incubation period if you will
before 9/11 and and to go back a little
bit after you completed your SEAL
training you joined you went to like a
sniper school what what is what is that
like yep actually when I went to seal I
went to SEAL team two after my SEAL
training and actually went screened and
went to SEAL Team six before I went to
Sniper school I didn't go to Sniper
school until I got to six I was at six
as an assaulter the door kicker we call
each other and then found out we needed
some more snipers and I volunteered to
go to sniper school sniper school I went
to was just south of you guys it's in
Quantico Virginia and it's the Marine
Corps Scout Sniper school and it's the
most storied you know prestigious and I
coulda went to any sniper school I
wanted to
I chose that school because I thought
that was the best night for school at
the time and what exactly is sniper
school like oh gosh you know what it's
like up there in the wood in the summer
time right now imagine laying in the
middle of a field in the summertime with
heavy clothes on
crawling through ticks red ants
mosquitoes and everything else and doing
that for like three or four hours a day
and without trying to be without getting
seen still making your shot sweating
profusely and you know even when you're
not doing your shooting
your range skills and stuff you're still
observing doing field sketches taking
notes observing and keeping that hot
suit on moving around and you know
that's that was tough and I tell
everybody Sniper school wasn't as bad as
hell week but it was pretty close so
when someone who's already enables see
Navy SEAL decides they want to try and
join Team six so first of all is there
just only a certain number that can be
in team six and how many people go out
for it there is Manning requirements for
SEAL Team six just like there are any
any military unit I'm not a liberty to
tell you how many people are at six but
how many people are accepted depends on
how many people they need how many
people are rotating out you know because
you can't stay at six and do that job
forever not being a Salter not be an
effective one and if you try to then
you're pushing that age limit Tommy's
gonna slow down etc you stick around and
be a trainer or something like that but
you've got to still have that fresh
group of assaulters those door kickers
coming back in so based on their needs
it depends on how many people they will
screen for and it will actually screen
for more than they need because
invariably somebody's gonna get hurt you
know getting dropped from training or
whatever now if somebody doesn't make it
the first time is this a test that
someone can continue to take over and
over I've never heard of someone being
dropped from Green Team at SEAL Team six
and that training and then then being
allowed to come back I think this is the
one one-shot deal but I say that hasn't
happened but I'm pretty sure I've never
heard of that usually if you don't make
it there you just go back you know to
wherever you came from and I've never
heard anybody coming back again unless
like I said it's a medical injury that
you know medical thing that you had no
control over
you know maybe then go heal up and come
back that's the same way in buds you
know if you get hurt in buds and it's
not your fault you know for example had
it we had a guy get slammed onto the
rocks doing rock portage and really hurt
him I mean like really hurt him
and he stayed around about six or seven
months rehabbing and then continuing his
training and and if you can say around
how long does someone stay in SEAL Team
six this is this is what I've
brainstormed and this is what I think I
think from six years to maybe eight
years in my opinion would be the max
amount of time because you can't take
that tempo that op tempo that day-in
day-out grind that beating every single
day up and down the stairs carrying
equipment just training perpetually and
having no really no personal life to
speak of that we're talking about a
lifestyle you'd have to imagine doing
your job for a living and being involved
in it every single day and being called
up anytime at night to do the job so I
would say if I had to put a number on at
6 to 8 years would be your shelf life
for being at that team and that would be
my next question is for people who are
involved in such a covert ops group what
impact does that have on their families
I assume they can't discuss it with
their families oh yeah I mean that's
tough I mean when I when I went to SEAL
team two somebody told me the divorce
rate among seals was like 70% okay so if
you're looking at a you know whose
divorce rate is already around 70% now
you're going to a unit where you're away
from your family more you're doing more
classified stuff that you can't talk
about for example when I went to Desert
Storm my wife back then knew I was going
to Desert Storm when I'd leave to go do
something from SEAL Team six she never
knew where I was going
she didn't know I was in Mogadishu you
know she found out I was shot just like
everybody else when the Red Cross caught
her and go hey guess what husband shot
three times but um I think that if
people who go there have it harder and
in their family life and their personal
life then other than the regular teams
so I think that you kind of got to take
a break of that after a while when
people heard the news that one binlong
had been shot that it was SEAL Team six
everybody wanted to know who these
people were
but they kind of want to stay in the
background is just just the nature of
the seals or is it because of the
missions that they do it's definitely
the mission you hear about seals two
ways to evening
when suddenly goes really really bad
like with me on my last stop where
something goes really good was the two
times you've heard about seals things
going really good when they shot two
Somali pirates you know and when bin
Lunz was killed
I can guarantee you do it all the Intel
that these guys got when they raided
that compound and about AB odd that
there's ops that have gone on since then
that none of us know about and don't
need to know about and here's the thing
though and here's the sad thing there's
probably been a dozen books written on
SEAL Team 6 minimum a dozen books by
different members and etc but um nobody
really cared about it until bin long was
killed so these are unsung heroes so
it's okay to like read the books and
that's first of all the reason I wrote
this book is so people could do two
things see the amount of training
preparation dedication and sacrifice
that these young men make and the other
thing is is to overcome adversity
hardest thing I ever did was leave SEAL
Team 6 and come back to civilian life
which almost cost me my life I mean I
was really really in a bad place there
so it's okay to know about him it's okay
to talk about him just don't try to
involve yourself in her personal life
you know I heard it there was a group of
people trying to find out who they were
stuff like that now we're crossing the
line but I think it's okay to talk about
them and I think that America should be
glad that we you know have people like
this that are willing to go there and do
that yeah when you made that comment
about you know transitioning into
civilian life how does somebody who goes
through that kind of intense training
make that transition in are some of them
not really able to make it yep here's
what I understand or what I think most
people do that leave that first of all
you're coming out with a very unique
skillset you know I mean it's not like
you're coming out with anything that's
like really marketable so a lot of
people get to a SWAT team you know some
some letter team like FBI DEA some
people go to work for organizations like
Blackwater or whatever they change
they've changed their name to now which
is what I was about to do until my wife
Debbie told me out of it and luckily
because I'd either be older and less
tactical now
or more dead so but in my particular
case coming out I'll give you this it
was harder for me because had three
bullet wounds that cost me my career I
was going through a divorce I had PTSD
and wasn't willing to admit it because
I'm a Navy SEAL I can't tell you that
I'm and I viewed it as a weakness I PTSD
the other thing I had that I didn't
realize I had put on my doctors hat now
looking back was survivor's guilt you
know how come so many good guys one guy
material I talk about in the book how
come how many how come these good guys
died and I was allowed to live and you
think that you should just be grateful
for that but it really weighs on
sometimes even now I'll still find
myself thinking you know how come this
guy died and I was allowed to live so
having all that weighing on me
coming back into society was really hard
trying to assimilate back in so I was
like lucky I met the right woman went
back to school became a chiropractor and
now I again have a job that I love and
that's the thing about seals they've got
to have a job they love can't be
lukewarm and you got to really be making
a difference that's the whole thing and
a seals hard is being able to make a
difference being someone special and at
one particular point can you talk about
the the missions that you were on yeah
and see that's a good point because my
book couldn't even be written until now
so yeah I think we finished about a year
and a half ago Tiffany but we had to
wait for everything that happened with
the CIA and Somalia to be out in the
open Declassified and the chief of
station did an interview in The
Washington Post and laid everything out
so like okay now we can talk about it I
mean Martin Bowden thought about it when
he did the Black Hawk Down thing and and
that's the cornerstone of my book is you
know that all there's some other ops in
there that I did in Desert Storm and
stuff but once something's Declassified
then you can talk about it but you still
don't talk about tactics and techniques
which if you you know the seals that are
read my book ago oh no we wouldn't do it
like that exactly you know so that's the
way it is
for more information on c-span's local
content vehicles and the 2011 LCV cities
tour visit c-span org slash local
content